you have to have more than idea if you
want to be successful in business you
need more than just an idea hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today
maintain a question from a YouTube
viewer couche who are in the same hi
Evan I would like to sell my idea to
companies i'm not going to offer the
service i just want to sell the idea
this is a hard one companies don't buy
ideas and I hate to pour rain on your
your idea here but if you want to have a
success if you want to build this into
something it's not just going up the
company's insane hey here's something
this company should do and then they're
going to pay me for I have lots of ideas
for companies and what they can do I'm
sure you do too i'm sure everybody does
what if Disney did this what a Pepsi did
this what if whatever company right we
all have ideas what if Starbucks did
this they're not going to pay you for it
you could have the greatest idea in the
world I have a hundred ideas that
Starbucks could use but they don't pay
me for so I'm not gonna waste my time on
it you need to have more than an idea
you have to have execution somewhere if
all you're doing is going in with an
idea a they may have already thought
about it and they probably have if there
are any size that priority thought
something about it but even if they
haven't thought about it it's not useful
to them because they need the execution
somebody has to do it the value is in
the execution and if they're doing
everything it's not worth it for them
there's so much politics that happen at
a big company that it's already hard
enough to sell their own ideas and line
up the resources and the budgets to make
it happen for somebody outside to come
in and say hey here's a great idea for
you it's going to take up tons of
resources time energy and I want you to
pay me for it not going to happen your
best chance is you need to have
something else that you're bringing
that's valuable you need to help with
the execution need to provide a service
otherwise they're not going to buy from
you you're gonna be wasting your time
and I hate to give you this bad news but
i just don't want to see you wasting
your time calling up on these companies
and either getting lapped out the door
or the match using your idea and not
compensating you for it which can happen
to so
to the drawing board figure out what you
can do to offer more value than just
trying to give them the idea those are
you watching you need to have more than
idea for your business you got to do the
work and ideas not enough everybody can
be in an idea person and a lot of
entrepreneurs are the idea people the
guys who are just the idea people rarely
make it you need to have the execution
you need to put the ideas into place and
the bigger the company you're trying to
pitch the harder it is you need more
than just the idea to those be watching
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up below and I want to hear from
you what do you think please leave a
comment below about this video or if you
have a question for your own company I
want to hear from you i love seeing
those come in so thank you guys and I'll
see you soon